Okay, good morning. So, today
we will do Germany and thus conclude our
discussion of the
four great civilizations that are
fighting for global dominance. We
previously did Britain, America,
Tuesday we did Russia, today we do
Germany.
So, to recap,
Russian civilization is very distinct
from American so Anglo-American
civilization
and German civilization is also distinct
as well. We're going to focus on the
idea of unity of will in German German
civilization today.
We don't know much about German
civilization because they were defeated
in World War II.
And because the Anglo-Americans control
the history
of the world, we tend to think
Anglo-American civilization is superior
to German and Russian civilization. But
what I will show you today is that in
many respects
the most advanced civilization that
humans have ever created is actually the
German civilization. Okay. So,
um
if you look at a map today in Europe,
there's a really interesting
fact that may surprise you. The green is
Russia.
Okay? It's the largest country in the
world. Over here are the Baltic nations.
And over here is a place called
Kaliningrad. It's actually Russian.
Okay? So, the question then is how did
this come to pass? How was it that
you've got this colony of Russians far
away from the motherland? And the answer
is this, because historically this was
not Russian.
Historically, this was a place called
Königsberg, which was part of a nation
that no longer exists called Prussia.
And for a couple hundred years Prussia
was the strongest military, the most
advanced civilization
in the world. And now it's disappeared.
And it's been replaced by Poland. Okay?
And parts of Belarus um and
West Prussia has it has all become part
of Germany. Okay? But um Prussia is no
longer
um it's extinct. And the reason why is
that in World War II the the allies who
won the war, the Soviet Union, the
British and Americans decided to destroy
Prussia.
And the rationale was that um Prussia is
a militaristic society that is hell-bent
on world domination.
And by eliminating Prussia, we can now
bring peace to the world. Um the problem
though is that um Königsberg, which is
now Kaliningrad, was really the center
of civilization
for a few decades. This is Königsberg
before in 1800s. As you can see, it's a
beautiful um port city
by the Baltic Sea.
Um
and it was really the apex of human
civilization.
And then of course World War II happened
and then after World War II
um Kaliningrad Königsberg was destroyed.
Okay? It was turned into rubble.
And today it's like this, Kaliningrad.
Okay? A very Soviet uh stale uh city
with no character, with no culture, with
no civilization. All right? And that's
the intent, to turn
uh to destroy Königsberg, which is which
was for the longest time the heart and
soul of German civilization.
Um it is true that Königsberg and
Prussia were extremely powerful what was
extremely powerful military uh nation.
And as you can see, uh this is from
Wikipedia by the way, okay?
Um as you can see, there are many great
generals and officers who are from
Königsberg. Okay? We're talking about
the city. We're not We're not talking
about the the nation Prussia. We're
talking about the city of Königsberg.
But you will also see that
um there are many
intellectuals, writers, who come from
Königsberg. Okay? And the most famous of
these intellectuals is Immanuel Kant,
which which will who we will discuss
next class. He basically changed the
course of Western history with his
philosophy. So, Königsberg was the
birthplace of Immanuel Kant. So, how is
it that the man who is most responsible
for the enlightenment
uh happens to be born in a militaristic
nation? Okay? That's that's a question.
But not only Immanuel Kant, uh but you
have also many other great thinkers,
including Hannah Arendt, who is a Jewish
philosopher and who is considered one of
the greatest um political philosophers
of the 20th century. She's also from
Königsberg.
Um scientists, just an amazing
group of scientists as well as uh
mathematicians. Okay?
And then you of course you have
musicians and artists. So, the
contribution of Königsberg towards
civilization cannot be
overstated.
Um
and there are quite a
there are quite a few Jews who lived in
Königsberg. Königsberg for the longest
time was considered one of the most
tolerant cities in Germany for Jews.
Um I we let's now look at
Nobel Prize winners in the sciences,
physics, chemistry, and medicine. Um as
you can see, in 1925 the majority were
actually from Germany. Okay? Germany had
the best scientists in the world. 1933,
same thing. You go to 1950, same thing.
In fact,
by 1975
Germany is still dominant. The United
States is catching up. It's only by
about 2000 when the United States starts
to take over overtake Germany. So again,
the question then is how is it possible
for a militaristic nation hell-bent on
world domination, how are they able to
produce so many great scientists, so
many great philosophers?
Um
and this is a very famous quote from
Voltaire that captures the prejudice of
the West against Prussia.
Where some states have an army, the
Prussian army has a state.
Okay?
Uh this is pretty insulting to Prussian
culture.
Um we've looked at many civilizations
that are militaristic, okay? Including
the Romans, Spartans, Aztecs,
Macedonians, and Qing Chinese among
others. They're extremely successful
militar militarily, but guess what? They
were not creative. In fact, they were
anti-creative.
So, how is it possible for the Prussians
to be both creative and militaristic?
And the answer is because the Western
prejudice against Prussia is wrong. They
were not a militaristic nation bent on
world domination. They were first and
foremost a creative humanistic society
that was forced into military military
military confrontation with neighbors
because of of its geographical location.
Okay?
Um so,
let's go back to the history of the Holy
Roman Empire. As we discussed in a
previous class, the Holy Roman Empire
was a confederation of German
city-states. And there were like
thousands and thousands of them that
were in competition with each other.
Okay?
Over time, because of competition from
uh the more powerful states like France,
uh Poland, Lithuania, Russia, Sweden,
these city-states were now forced to gel
together. The most successful of of
these city-states is Prussia. Okay? And
for the longest time Prussia was a
vassal state of the Polish uh Lithuanian
Commonwealth uh or the Swedes. Okay? But
but but by about year 1700 it started to
come into its own through the leadership
of for great military leadership. Okay?
And it started to spread out.
Um and as you can see, it's spreading
out really quickly because of its
military victories and because of its
high culture. Um by the 19th century
Prussia has dedicated itself to uniting
all of Germany. And it starts a series
of wars that allow for the unification
of all the German people. The first is
something called the Danish-Prussian
War. Then they fight against the
Austrian-Hungary Empire, which is a
successor to the Holy Roman Empire. And
they defeat the Austrians really
quickly. Then they move on to France,
which is the dominant power of this
time. And they defeat France, thus
allowing for the complete unification of
Germany under Prussian leadership.
Okay.
So, how was Prussia able to be so
successful? Well, as we discussed last
class, there are certain characteristics
about these city-states that go on to
unify a nation. Okay? And the three
major ones that that Moscow and Prussia
share is open cooperative competition.
They're surrounded by enemies and
they're forced to be innovative, open,
and tolerant in order to
succeed. They're forced to be unified.
Uh advantaged by disadvantage. Okay? So,
Prussia and Moscow have limited
resources, which forces them to focus on
human capital, on making sure the
citizens citizens were well educated and
the citizens were um hard working and
vassalage, okay? So again, Moscow was
under the vassalage
of the of the Mongols and Prussia for
the longest time was under the vassalage
of the Swedes, the
Poles, Lithuanians. And as a result,
they're always engaged in a process of
reflection and resilience, okay? And
that's really the secret to the success
of Prussia. All right. At the same time,
the thing to remember about the
Prussians that differentiates them from
from the Muscovites is because Prussia
is situated within Europe, it has a very
different attitude towards humans than
the Muscovites, okay? The Muscovites,
because of their Mongolian heritage,
they tend to oppress their subjects,
whereas the Prussians are much more
democratic, they're much more
progressive, they're much more open,
okay? So this is Frederick the Great,
who is considered the great nation
builder of Prussia through his military
victories. What is often ignored is his
social, economic, political reforms. He
really is the first enlightenment
despot, okay? He's heavily influenced by
Immanuel Kant. They thought very highly
of each other.
And he was he was very intent on making
Prussia the first enlightened state of
Europe, okay? So let's look at the few
things he did. He radically reformed the
Prussian judicial system so that you had
rule of law, so that everyone had
recourse to justice, no matter
even if you were poor, you could still
sue.
He abolished torture in the military.
This is revolutionary at this time
because it was always assumed that you
kept your soldiers in check by scaring
them, okay?
He established he established religious
tolerance. Remember at this time in
Europe, there's a huge
war going on between Catholics and the
Protestants, and he was tolerant towards
both the Catholics and the Protestants
and even and even to a certain extent to
the Jews as well,
okay? And over time, Königsberg, which
is the heart and center of the Prussian
nation,
becomes really
one it has one of the largest Jewish
settlements in Europe, okay? About 5,000
at that point. He grants basic form of
freedom of speech.
And he and the most important thing is
that in 1763, he establishes a public
school system that becomes a source for
Prussia's future greatness. And to put
this in context, okay? It's only over
100 years later when Britain and France
does this. Japan and America will copy
just basically steal the Prussian
education system, okay?
Um
In 1806,
Prussia is defeated by Napoleon. Okay,
we discussed this. And as a result,
Prussia becomes a vassal state to
Napoleon. And at this point, what the
Prussians do is what they've always
done, which is engage in a deep process
of reflection. And they decide that in
order to defeat France, they must be
like France. Remember this is the French
Revolution and there's a spread of
liberalism throughout France because of
the revolution. So the Prussians decide
to copy the most important reforms of
the French Revolution, which include the
abolishment of serfdom. Now peasants can
become land owners. They destroy
monopolies to encourage free market
competition. They open the civil service
to middle class. Before it was only
available to the nobility.
And the most important thing is the
reforms of a man named William von
Humboldt. He creates the modern research
university.
So so he founded something called the
Berlin University. And so he
conceptualized the research university
where before you sat in class and you
listened to lectures and you memorized
what the professor told you, but now
you're encouraged to do your own
research, to write a thesis, okay? Which
is what we do today. The most important
reform he did was to conceptualize
public education as a meritocracy, as an
opportunity for the middle class to
grow, okay? To grow the middle class and
to give the middle class a greater
economic role in society. And these
reforms in only a few years will allow
Prussia to defeat Napoleon and establish
itself as a great power again.
This is Carl von Clausewitz, and he's
considered the greatest military
strategist of all time. He's Prussian.
He he was an officer in the Prussian
military. And he thought very deeply
about the
sorry, the wars of Napoleon. Why is it
that the Napoleon and the French were so
great? And his conclusion is because
they were
because they were able to
mobilize the resources of society for
total war.
Okay? And his conclusion is that in the
future, as a nation, if you want to win
militarily, then you must engage your
citizens, okay? You must increase the
morale of your citizens. You must make
them want to want to die for your
nation.
All right?
is one of the most important years in
human history. And the reason why is in
1848, okay? These red spots, these are
all revolutionary hot spots, okay? So
after Napoleon was defeated in 1815,
the European powers led by Metternich
of the Austrian-Hungary Empire, he sits
everyone down and decides first of all
how to ensure no wars like like like
that of Napoleon arise again in Europe,
how to create peace, but also, most
important, how to maintain
the feudal structure of Europe, okay?
And he and they were very successful at
that until 1848 when the middle class
when the workers rebelled in
17 different places. You will notice
that in England, in Britain, there was
no revolution, there were no rebellions.
And the reason why is because Britain at
this point had colonies overseas, right?
Canada, New Zealand, Australia.
And so these people who were upset about
the
status in Britain could migrate
elsewhere. But these other places didn't
have have any colonies. There was no
pressure valve for social discontent,
and so these revolutions start to take
place. A lot of these revolutions were
suppressed violently. And you would
think that Prussia, because it is a
military dictatorship, it would suppress
the
the middle class liberals
violently. But that's not what happened,
okay? Let's see what happened.
So this is from Wikipedia. What happened
was that the republic administrations
because
people wanted more political reforms,
right? And the army killed certain
people. And now people are really,
really angry. So they erect barricades.
They're they're getting ready for civil
war, okay? This is another French
Revolution.
And at this point, the emperor Frederick
William, what he does is he goes and
reassures the public that they will
negotiate a peace. And what he does to
calm the public is
the king also approved arming the
citizens. He gives guns to the citizens
to ensure that the citizens citizens
will feel safe negotiating with the
army, okay? But not only that,
but when the crowds of people
went to the king,
the king basically agreed to all their
demands, including parliamentary
elections, a constitution, and freedom
of the press.
Also, he promised everyone that Prussia
was to be merged forthwith into Germany.
Because not only is there liberal
socialist sentiments at this point,
there's also nationalist sentiments.
People want to feel united as a German
people, okay?
And then, what calms people down is the
king attends a funeral for those
citizens who died during the rebellion,
okay? And they wore
Okay, he and his ministers wore the
revolutionary tricolor, black, red, and
gold, which is by the way the the flag
of Germany right now, okay? So he's
showing tremendous respect to his
people, okay? And that's just the
Prussian attitude. Again, the the
historical image of Prussians is very
stern, very austere, very dictatorial,
okay? But if you look at their behavior,
they're very respectful of their people
because they understand that in this
world where they're surrounded by
enemies, they're a central power with
France, Russia,
all
around them, they need to stay united as
a people, okay?
This is Otto von Bismarck, the most
famous
Prussian in world history. He is the
founder of something called the Second
Reich. The Holy Roman Empire was the
First Reich. And the unified Germany is
the Second Reich. So he's really the
founder of
modern-day Germany. He's known as the
Iron Chancellor because he gave a speech
in which he said that the position of
Prussia in Germany will not be
determined by its liberalism, but by its
power, okay? So he's rejecting the idea
of liberalism, of free speech, of
openness, of negotiation, of
institutions, and he's focusing on the
military. Prussia must concentrate its
strength and hold it for the favorable
moment, which has already come and gone
several times. Since the treaties of
Vienna, our frontiers have been
ill-designed for a healthy body politic.
Not through speeches and majority
decisions will the great questions of
the day be decided. That was the great
mistake of 1848 and 1849, but by iron
and blood, okay? Through violence and
sacrifice. So, if you So, when you read
the speech, you understand that he's
repudiating the liberalism of King
Frederick Wilhelm, okay? He's saying
that, "Nope, the army should have gone
in and killed all the demonstrators,
okay?" So, that's what
he's saying, and that's why he has a
reputation for being the iron
chancellor, a man of violence, a man of
sternness, okay? But, he was extremely
pragmatic man.
And his ambition was to have a unified
Germany in which people were content.
Okay?
Um and so, this is another speech he
made.
Same man, but completely different tone.
And so, he says,
"The real grievance of the worker is the
insecurity of his existence. He's not
sure that he will always have work. He
is not sure that if he that he will
always be healthy. And he perceives that
he will one day be old and unfit to
work, okay?" So, he's sympathizing with
the plight of the factory worker. He
understands that
um it's wrong for workers to lose their
hand at work and not be compensated.
It's wrong for workers to get sick and
their entire family to go into poverty.
It's It's wrong for kids who are 6 years
old to go to factories to work. It's
wrong for managers to beat the crap out
of other factory workers. So, what they
will do is institute the first welfare
state, the first socialist state in the
world, okay? Look at this. They have
health insurance. They have accident
insurance. So, if you get if you get
injured in at work, then the state will
come in and uh give you money.
They have a pension. They protect
workers uh from abuse. They have
children protection act, which means
work children are not allowed to go work
in factories, okay? So, in other words,
in the year 1800 to 1900, if you could
be a citizen of anywhere in the world,
you would definitely want to be a
citizen of Germany, okay?
At this point, in Britain, in France, in
America, workers are being exploited
everywhere. But, in Germany, workers are
are being given rights. And because
they're being because they're giving
being given rights, they want to fight
for their country. They want to die for
their country. And this makes Germany
the most powerful nation
in the world at this time, okay? And
when that happens, in Europe, when you
become a hegemon,
guess who gets scared at you. Guess
who's now going to plot to get rid of
you. Britain, right?
All right.
So, um at the same time, I don't want to
say that Germany is a liberal democracy
at this point. It's not. Why? Because as
these industrial reforms are happening,
there are more groups that are
discontent, okay? And they pose a
problem to German unity, okay? And these
groups are obviously the Catholics. A
third of Germany now is Catholic because
Prussia has united all of Germany,
right? For the longest time, the Holy
Roman Empire was Catholic. So, a third
of all the people
um is Catholic.
Bismarck, his biggest failure, his
biggest mistake was his his attempt to
suppress the Catholics, okay? He
basically said, "Listen, we're not going
to fund you anymore, and if you insist
on swearing loyalty to the Pope, then we
will put you in prison. You will not
display loyalty to Germany." And so, the
priests all went to prison, okay? And
this was a disaster for Bismarck, and
ultimately he had to compromise and
relent, okay? So, the Catholics were a
huge problem. Then you have the
liberals, okay? So, you may have heard
the term liberalism, socialism,
communism. There's a huge difference
between these three terms, guys, okay?
So, so let me explain what the
differences are. Liberalism means more
political rights for the middle class,
right? Freedom of speech, freedom of
assembly, voting power. Why? Because the
middle class have economic power, and
they want to transform that into
political power, okay?
The socialists want democracy for all.
They understand
uh that um for democracy to really
happen, you need to provide worker
protection. You need to create class
consciousness. You need to let workers
have unions, okay?
So, that's socialism. Then you have
communism, which is more radical.
Basically, communists believe wealth
should be redistributed, okay? We should
get rid of private property
and redistribute wealth for more
equality in society. Also, communism is
an international movement, okay?
Um you also have Polish nationalists. A
lot of people in Germany at this time
are Poles. They're Slavic people who
have their own language, have their own
ethnic identity. And ultimately, they
they will form Poland, okay? And at this
time, they're a huge problem for the
German state, and they are suppressed as
well. Then you have people called the
anarchists.
Um the anarchists are people who believe
that
we don't need government. We don't need
authority. People should should just be
allowed to do whatever they want to do.
People are self-organizing, and as a
result, uh government is bad, okay? So,
you have all these different political
groups, and all are very powerful, and
they all pose a problem to German unity,
and as a result, they are persecuted one
by one.
Uh this is important because
um at the end of World War I, when
Germany has surrendered, they will
reflect on why they lost. And one
conclusion that they had was because of
all these political divisions, okay?
There are too many divisions within
society. Therefore, we need we we need
to suppress this division and create one
political entity. And this is what
allows for the rise, of course, of
Hitler and the Nazis, okay? So, this is
important to understand.
All right.
World War I. Again, when if Germany is
too powerful, Britain is forced into
action. Britain cannot allow for a
hegemon to be dominant in Europe.
Britain went into action against
Napoleon when Napoleon was a hegemon.
Now, they're going into action against
Germany because Germany is too powerful,
okay? And World War I, no one expected
this, but World War I was a catastrophe,
okay? Millions of people died. And it
was an alliance of
Britain, France, and Russia, basically
against Germany. I mean, Germany did
have the Ottoman Empire and the
Austria-Hungary Empire as allies, but
they were not effective. It was really
Germany versus the world. And what's
amazing is Germany was able to um create
a stalemate, or even at in in in there
was I I actually sometimes when Germany
was about to win, okay? And of course,
when that happens, if Germany is going
to win this war, it forces the Americans
into action.
Okay, why? Well, first of all, the
Americans think like the British.
The Americans and British do not want a
European power to emerge, to unite the
heartland, okay? To unite Asia and
Europe, because then it negates naval
trade, okay? Does that make sense?
Second reason is the Americans actually
lent a lot of money to the British,
okay? Something called a lend-lease
policy. So, if Britain lost the war,
then all that money is gone, okay? So,
Brit So, America comes in to save
Britain, okay? But, even at this point,
this is really important. Even at this
point, Germany,
it was not clear Germany was going to
lose the war, okay? Russia was knocked
out of the war, France was divided,
Britain was not affect was not that um
effectual. So, it was not clear at this
point um Germany was going to lose,
okay?
Chancellor Germany was going to lose,
but Germany had not lost yet. And if
Germany could mobilize all its
resources, then Germany could withstand
this this onslaught. But then, something
happened that was very important that
changed the mind, the calculus of these
German generals.
The 1917 Russian Revolution.
Why did the revolution happen? Because
Tsar Nicholas
was too focused on the war, and he
neglected the the um political divisions
at home, okay? And this allowed for a
revolution to happen. So, the German
generals who are controlling Germany at
this point, they're scared to death of
this happening in Germany. Because
remember, at this point in history,
the nation with the strongest working
class, the proletariat, is actually
Germany, not Russia, okay? So, as a
result, um the
This man's name is Paul von Hindenburg.
He's very important. He's now head of
the German military, as well as head of
the German nation. And he forced the
German government to surrender to the
allies.
Okay? And this led to the 1919 Treaty of
Versailles. The Treaty of Versailles
had many stipulations that were unfair
to the Germans, okay? So, the Germans
had to pay a lot of debt.
Uh they had they could no longer rearm.
They had to reduce their military. They
lost a lot of a lot of land to France,
okay? But, the worst thing that the
allies did um in this negotiation was it
forced Germany
to admit complete guilt for starting the
war.
That was completely unfair, okay? This
war happened for many reasons. Everyone
was involved. Everyone had a certain
blame. But, Germany had to take all the
blame.
Okay? And as a result, the government
did not want to sign this
um
uh treaty because obviously, this is
going to piss off all your people. But,
the army forced the government to sign
the treaty, okay? And the thinking of
the army at this point is
Listen, we've been in this in this
situation before, okay? We lost to
Napoleon,
right? And so, we just paid off a lot of
debt to Napoleon, and then we rebuilt,
okay? And when when we when we rebuilt,
we made we we we made the nation
stronger. We're resilient. So, we'll do
we'll do we'll do the same thing here,
okay? We'll just surrender, accept all
the terms, then we'll start to rebuild
and unify the nation and take take take
revenge against everyone, okay? And that
And that was like the thinking of the
military, okay?
Very simple strategy, right?
Um the Weimar Republic is what follows
after the war. And the Weimar Republic
is um 10 years of hyperinflation, social
discontent, complete chaos, okay? And
when a nation suffers economically,
politically, socially, what it often
does is it engages in a deep process of
reflection. It goes back into the past
and thinks about how to rebuild itself,
okay? So,
some philosophers that are very
important uh for thinkers of how to
unify Germany
um are
are like Arthur Schopenhauer, okay?
Arthur Schopenhauer is a very very
important philosopher. All right? His
conception of the world is
that the underlying force of the world
is the will, okay? Desire.
And the will manifests manifests itself
itself physically in us in bodies, okay?
Do you Do you understand the idea, okay?
So, the underlying force of the universe
is the will, desire. And then the will
will physically manifest itself in our
bodies.
And then our bodies will seek to do what
the will wants, which is to procreate,
right? To have sex, to have children, to
eat food,
okay? Now, the great
um
the great the paradox of this situation
is
before our the manifestation in our
bodies, the will was just one, right?
There was no differentiation. But, once
the will manifests itself in our bodies,
there's now differentiation, okay?
There's multi- multi- multiplicity, and
as such, we see the world through our
own perspective, through our own selfish
perspective, which leads to conflict.
You understand? It is because we
forgotten that we are just one that
leads to conflict and suffering.
Okay? So, his great solution to this is
compassion. As humans, we must first and
foremost be compassionate towards each
other and remind ourselves that we are
just one people,
okay? And we can do that through the
appreciation appreciation of art,
because art is a great unifier, right?
Art is is the thing that allows us to
contemplate the wholeness and the
harmony of the world. And then he says
that there's some of us who should
engage in self-denial, who who should
become like monks, who should deny who
should deny the world, because the world
is inherently evil,
right? So, when you refuse to have
children, when you refuse to struggle,
to suffer, then you achieve
enlightenment, okay? And I And And this
isn't easy for us to understand, because
this is a very Buddhist
ideology, okay? So, he's basically
taking Buddhism and Hinduism from India
and and he's making it more secular.
He's trying to remove the religious
aspects of it and make it into a logical
system, okay? Does that make sense?
All right. So,
he says, "Life has no intrinsic worth,
but is kept in motion merely by desire
and illusion. And as such, if you can
remove the desire from your life, you
achieve nirvana, you achieve
enlightenment, okay?"
Um
This is a really important passage,
okay? "Music is thus by no means like
the other arts, the copy of the ideas,
but the copy of the will itself, whose
objectivity the ideas are. This is why
the effect of music is so much more
powerful and penetrating than that of
the other arts. For they speak only of
shadows, but it speaks of the thing
itself." Okay, this is really important.
So, how do we know the will?
How can we access the will? It's through
music, okay? Because the music is a
perfect encapsulation of desire,
right? It is the perfect expression
of emotions.
And so, through music,
we can rediscover the unity of the
world, the unity of the will. And the
why is it why is this important? Because
it inspires
Richard Wagner, okay? Richard Wagner is
the most famous musician in Germany.
He's really the national poet of
Germany.
He's a genius, and his great insight is
that all art can can can be combined
into one, okay? And this is before
movies, right? This is this is before
cinema. So, you can put in music,
paintings, theater,
uh
poetry, philosophy, everything together
to create one total art that will
inspire and unite the people. And this
is why he spends 30 years to create
something called the Ring trilogy, okay?
And this is held every year at the
Bayreuth Festival. He He creates his own
opera house in order to stage a play,
and it's
15 hours, okay? It's It's four parts,
15 hours, and it's the inspiration for
The Lord of the Rings movies. I'm sure
you've you've seen The Lord of the
Rings, right? It's a very similar plot,
okay? And the plot's
um
very simple. It's 15 hours. Sorry, it's
not a simple plot, but I'll I'll I'll
put it in very simple terms. It's 15
hours, four parts, okay? So,
um there are people called the
Rhinemaidens, okay? These are These are
river goddesses who control the river
Rhine, and they have a lot of gold. Uh
there's a dwarf, an evil dwarf, who
steals all this gold, and with all this
gold, he crafts a ring to control the
world, okay? To rule the world. And this
is This is important, because it's
actually taking Schopenhauer's
philosophy, right? Desire is the source
of evil in the world, and turning it
into a metaphor. The ring is desire.
The ring is what represents evil and
suffering in the world. And because we
all seek the ring, we cause misery.
All right? Okay. So, um
this is what This is how it starts. Now,
up in
the sky, there's a god named Wotan,
okay? Uh this is So, Wagner's using a
lot of Norse mythology that that we
learned before from the Vikings, right?
Wotan is another name for Odin.
And Wotan and the gods want to create a
palace for themselves called Valhalla,
okay? And they hire a giant to build
this Valhalla, okay? And they sign a
contract with him.
But, the giants want payment first,
okay? So, Wotan and the gods steal this
ring from the dwarf, okay? And they give
it to the giant. But, then the dwarf
places a curse on this ring. And the
curse is um that the gods will see the
their end, the end of days, Ragnarok,
every day, okay? So, the gods are
haunted, and so,
um the gods are like, "We need to
destroy this ring. Otherwise, we're
always going to be haunted.
We we won't won't be able to sleep."
Okay? And so, they need to kill the
giant and get the ring back. But, they
they have a contract with this giant.
So, Odin
or Wotan conspires
to
uh give birth to a great hero who's half
human, half god, but he's not fully god,
who will now go kill the giant and get
the ring back, okay? That's That That
That's his great
um idea.
Um
So, he So, he gives birth to twins,
Sieglinde and Siegmund. They're
separated at birth. Uh they're twins,
and then they run into each other and
they fall in love with each other.
Remember, they're they're twins, okay?
Uh Sieglinde is already married, and so,
Siegmund is determined to kill her
husband, Hunding, and marry Sieglinde,
okay? And this is all part of Wotan's
plan. He's really happy. But, then his
wife, Fricka, says to him, "Um no no no
no no.
They broken the incest law, okay?
They're not allowed to have sex with
each other.
And so, you have to kill Siegmund." And
Wotan
um doesn't really have a choice in the
matter. He has to He has to agree to the
death of
uh Siegmund, okay? So, he sends his
daughter, a Valkyrie named Brünnhilde,
to go make sure
that Siegmund uh is killed against
Hunding. But, Brünnhilde, when she
arrives, she sees the love between
Sieglinde and and um sorry, Sieglinde
and Siegmund, and she wants to save
Siegmund and defy Wotan's orders.
Wotan hears about this and punishes
Brünnhilde and kills Siegmund uh
Siegmund, okay?
And what he does by punishing Brünnhilde
is he sentences her to eternal sleep,
surrounded by a wall of flames. Only the
greatest hero in the world, the hero who
is capable of killing the giant and uh
retrieving the ring, can save her. And
this hero is named Siegfried, who's the
son of Siegmund,
okay? This is Act three now. Siegfried
saves her, um
kills the giant, and
uh
now has retrieved the ring. But, because
he has the ring now, everyone around him
is now conspiring to kill him and um get
the ring for themselves, okay? The
problem of desire, which causes misery.
So, in the end, what happens is that um
Siegfried is killed, Brünnhilde learns
of this
um treachery, and then she kills those
who killed him, and then
what she does is she sacrifices herself
in the flames and throws with ring back
to the river maidens, okay? And then
what happens in this this is the ending
is the river maidens destroy the ring.
But when they destroy the ring, they
destroy everything, okay? They destroy
Valhalla as well. The gods are
destroyed. Valhalla is destroyed. The
entire world is destroyed. Okay? And
this goes back to Schopenhauer idea that
the source of the world is desire, okay?
When you destroy desire, you destroy the
world. But when you do that, you allow
for new beginning.
Okay? So that's the
uh
national epic of Germany, the ring
cycle. And again, this is put on every
year at Bayreuth. It's four nights um
and it's 15 hours in total. There's some
um theaters that put on a 15-hour
straight, okay? And the Germans love
this.
All right? So I'm going to play for you
some music from
this opera. And this is the most famous
part called the Ride of the Valkyries,
okay?
As you can see, it's very powerful,
right? It represents the unity of the
will.
So as people are watching this, they
become united as one.
Time, space collapse. Past, present
collapse.
This is meant to depict
the will, the unity of the will.
Okay, that's it. All right.
All right, let's move on, okay? So um
building on top of Wagner
and uh Schopenhauer is Friedrich
Nietzsche, okay? Who's considered one of
the greatest German philosophers
of all
time, okay? And he and he
um makes some corrections to the
philosophy of Schopenhauer and the music
of Wagner.
All right?
Um
here are the three major differences
between Schopenhauer and Nietzsche.
You can see that Schopenhauer, he's a
pessimistic Plato, okay? Whereas
Nietzsche, he's an optimistic Aristotle.
So Nietzsche's main complaint is this.
Okay, Schopenhauer's conception is the
source of everything is desire. And from
desire met desire manifests itself in
physical bodies in order to obtain what
it wants, okay? And that's true. That
makes sense.
And then Schopenhauer's solution is that
we must deny this desire, okay? We must
negate this desire and then we'll bring
peace to the world.
So for Nietzsche, this is confusing
because
um
wait a minute here.
The desire, the will manifests itself in
physical bodies.
Why would it do that? What's the logic
of that, okay? And Schopenhauer would
say, "Well, because God is evil. Because
God wants us to suffer."
And then
Nietzsche is like, "Okay.
Um first of all, if if if God is evil,
what's the point of resisting him?
Right?
If it brings us enjoyment
to seek desire, then what's wrong with
it?
Is it possible that God is good
and
that God lets desire manifest itself in
our in us
in order for us to pursue our desire?
Okay? So this is one of the major
differences. For Schopenhauer,
we are just biological
uh
beings that have a will to life. We want
to procreate.
But for Nietzsche, it's the will to
power, okay? This is a very very famous
phrase from Nietzsche, the will to
power, the will to expand ourselves,
okay? The will to achieve our fullest
desires.
Okay? Not just to procreate, but to
impose our will on reality itself.
That's the true purpose of life.
That's why God created us, to become
gods ourselves.
Cuz otherwise, this makes no sense.
How do we go from desire to bodies?
It only makes sense if
the bodies can amplify our desire and
help us achieve our desire, okay? The
will to power. This is a really
important concept.
Schopenhauer believes that multiplicity
is conflict. The fact that we this will
manifest itself in our bodies can only
lead to conflict because we're all
fighting for
um scarce resources. For example, uh the
ability to procreate, okay? But for
Nietzsche, multiplicity is creativity.
It's because there's conflict that you
have action and action leads to
innovation. And innovation by itself is
progress.
Okay?
And so
for Schopenhauer, the ideal person, the
superman is the compassionate monk, the
person who feels sympathy for the world
and as such engages in a process of
self-denial, self-negation.
He refuses to procreate. He refuses to
struggle. He refuses to eat, okay? The
monk.
But for Nietzsche, the ideal is the
Ubermensch. The Ubermensch The
Ubermensch is hard to translate. We
usually translate it as superman, but
you can also translate it as overman,
okay? The person above humanity, the
person above history. So the ideal the
paragon uh the example that Nietzsche
uses is Napoleon, right? Who is
Napoleon? Napoleon is an individual who
can step outside of history to control
history, to manipulate history. That's
what the Ubermensch is.
Okay? We we ourselves are always
controlled by social forces, right? We
don't want to piss off our classmates.
We want to please our teachers and our
parents. So therefore, we are slaves to
public opinion.
But Nietzsche says to be an Ubermensch,
you have to ignore
public opinion. You have to ignore
community consensus and just focus on
what is right to you, to look deep into
yourself
and figure out what is right for you and
only you.
Okay, that's the Ubermensch. And for
him, the ideal example, of course, is
Napoleon. Okay? And why is this
important? Because his ideas
in the context of Weimar Republic will
lead to the rise of the Nazis and
Hitler, okay? Because Hitler is
promising himself to be the next
Napoleon. Right? That's Hitler's promise
to the German people. I will be your
Napoleon. I will unite you. I will lead
you to victory against all enemies.
All right?
Okay.
Does that make sense, guys?
Are you Are you guys following this?
All right.
So let's look at a couple passages from
Nietzsche, okay? Nietzsche is a very
brilliant philosopher, so he's very
complicated. He's very complex. Um and
he and he he he he he he has a tendency
to be very contradictory, okay?
All right.
So let's read a passage from the
genealogy of morals, which is his is
which is his most famous book.
"We can no longer conceal from ourselves
precisely what this will under the
direction of the ascetic ideal
expresses, which is hatred of anything
human, animal, or material, abhorrence
of the senses, of reason itself, fear of
happiness and beauty, the desire to
escape from all illusion, change,
growth, death, wishing even from desire
itself. All this means, let us have the
courage to confront it, a wish for
oblivion, an aversion to life, a
reputation rep reputation of everything
vital to existence, but it is and
remains a will. Let us say at the end
that which I said at the beginning, men
will desire oblivion rather than not
desire at all. We are desire, okay? It's
it's really a question of how we
manifest our desire.
In today's society, in the Christian
Buddhist world worldview, it's important
to negate our desire.
But when we negate our desire, we negate
what our desire could lead us to, which
is truth and beauty
and creativity and progress and
innovation.
Okay? And when we neg- negate ourselves,
we're not returning back to unity, we
are only embracing oblivion.
Okay? That's the problem with
Christianity. It's all It's showing us
into slaves. That's the problem with
modernity. That's the problem with
society. We are all being forced to
become slaves.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right, let's go on.
"To call the tamed animal improving it
sounds to ears almost like a joke. He
who knows what goes on in menageries
doubts very much whether an animal is
improved in such places. It certainly
weakened. It is made less dangerous and
by means of the depressing influence of
fear, pain, wounds, and hunger, it is
converted into a sick animal. And the
same holds good of the tamed man whom
the priest has improved." Okay? This is
a great metaphor. How can we understand
the impact of society on people? Well,
society is a zoo, okay? We're all caged
animals.
If you think about it, okay? What is
school then?
School is a zoo,
okay? Before you were allowed to run
around and explore the world and learn
things for yourself, right? And as such,
you mastered the world around you. You
could hunt. You could farm. You could
kill people. You could build alliances.
You could write plays. But in school,
what do we ask you to do? We ask you to
come to school. We we ask you to come to
class on time.
Take notes. Take tests. And then we give
you a piece of paper, right? We turn you
into caged animals. So you lose the
capacity to think for yourself.
Right? That's what school is. So there's
nothing wrong with what Nietzsche is
saying, okay? This is a really good
metaphor to capture the essence of
modernity.
Okay?
Society,
education, it's all meant to degrade
your capacity to think for yourself
in order to make you more obedient
to power, okay?
All right. So,
um if you take Schopenhauer, Wagner, and
Nietzsche together, and you combine
them, what you get is a rejection of
Christianity and return to paganism.
Okay? So, let's go to the differences.
In the Christian worldview, there is a
God. If there's a God, there's a there
is a framework of good and evil. So, you
must do good and you must avoid evil,
okay?
But in the pagan worldview, there is no
God. There's There's many gods, but the
gods themselves have no power over fate.
And as a result, it is up to you to
define good and evil. It's up to you
to act and to find meaning in the world.
Okay? So, but going back to school, the
metaphor, right? Today we have grades,
and therefore
you're focused on getting grades. But if
we had no grades, we had no teachers,
then you have to go learn for yourself.
You have to You would have to go through
your own education. What's amazing about
this idea is you would want to, because
Nietzsche says we are first and foremost
desire. We desire to grow. So, if if we
left you alone and said, "No grades, no
school, no test." It does not mean that
you will stop learning. It just means
that you will learn what you want to
learn.
Okay?
All right. Second difference.
Christianity demands faith, obedience to
God. Paganism demands action.
Okay?
You seek meaning for yourself through
action.
The last difference is Christianity
focus on individual free will.
Okay? Which just means you are free to
obey the powerful.
But in the pagan um mindset, it's about
unity of will, okay? If we If we want to
act, we can only do so by working
together.
All right? We will find a leader to lead
us,
but the leader only represents the unity
of will.
Okay? Does that make sense?
So, during the Weimar Republic, with the
rise of Nazism, you now have a a
rejection of Christianity and return to
paganism as a solution to the national
humiliation of Germany.
All right? And this is what leads to the
rise of Adolf Hitler, okay? This man is
Paul von Hindenburg. The very The same
man who ordered the surrender of
Germany.
In 1933, he is president of Germany, the
leader, and he appoints
Adolf Hitler the chancellor
of
uh Germany, okay? Now, the question then
is
why would he do that? Right?
Yeah, I mean like why would the head of
the army, the head of the nation, make
Adolf Hitler
uh chancellor? And the reason is this.
Adolf Hitler was a German spy. He was a
German Sorry, sorry. He was a spy for
the German army.
Okay? Let Let Let This is really
important. Let me explain this. This is
from Wikipedia, guys, okay? So, I'm not
I'm not making this up. It says very
clearly,
as an intelligence agent of the army,
Hitler's job was to influence other
soldiers into infiltrate the German
Workers' Party, okay? The Nazi Party,
National Socialists. Okay. So, what Why
is this happening?
So, remember, the German army
surrendered because they were afraid of
revolution back at home. Who's leading
the revolution?
The extreme left and extreme right.
Okay? What's the difference between
extreme left and extreme right? Both are
populists. They all They all believe in
workers' rights. The left believe in
international solidarity, okay?
Specifically with Russia, the Soviet
Union, and other workers in the world.
The right are nationalists. They believe
in German unity.
Okay? So, the army is like, "Okay.
Right now, the most powerful group in
Germany are the socialists, right? The
left. We need to support the right." So,
Hitler goes into
the Nazi Party, the German Workers'
Party, and he helps to finance it, okay?
Hitler's giving money to these guys.
And because he's such a charismatic
speaker, he eventually becomes their
leader. By this point in history, okay?
This is really important. This is a
really small group of people. They're
extreme, they're violent, but they are a
minority. The majority are the
socialists, okay?
This is something that you're not taught
in school,
but this is very important to remember.
It is the army that finances the
building of the Nazi Party
in order to
get rid of the influence
of the socialists.
Okay? Because remember, the army now is
still dedicated to uh avenging the
national humiliation of World War I.
Okay?
All right.
So, uh this is Carroll Quigley, and he
wrote a long book called Tragedy and
Hope, okay? And he explains in uh So,
sorry. Carroll Quigley, he is a
professor. He was a professor at
Georgetown University in Washington,
D.C. He was Bill Clinton's teacher,
okay? He was Bill Clinton's uh teacher.
Um and he's a a widely respected
scholar. And in his In his book, he
explains how Hitler was able to rise and
take over the leadership of Germany.
Um he explains at this point in history
that Germany is threatened by two
opposing forces. The first force, of
course, is communism,
right? The Soviet Union. That's a huge
menace to Germany. But another menace
that's even actually even more menacing
is capitalism.
Okay? Because at this point in history,
what's happening is the international
capitalists are trying to create a
central banking system in order to
control the entire global economy. Okay?
And he He writes about this. This is
1920s.
The powers of financial capitalism had
another far-reaching aim, nothing less
than create a world system of financial
control in private hands able to
dominate the political system of each
country and the economy of the world as
a whole. Okay? This is really important
to understand. 1920s,
all these bankers in the world, America,
Britain, France, Germany, they're
getting together, and they're conspiring
on how to create a global financial
system
that can control the world and create a
feudal system.
Right? And guess what, guys?
You don't know this, but they succeeded.
The system we have today is the one they
created.
Okay? But But But But I will explain
this later on in the course, okay? But
this is something that the Germans,
nationalists like Hitler, didn't want.
Okay.
So,
um
Hitler, he's allowed to rise, and the
Nazi Party is is becoming more and more
popular. But again, even though they are
popular, they're not as popular as the
socialists, okay? So, what what happens
now is the army and the Nazi Party get
together
and uh assume power, okay? So, uh the
first step for Hitler
in order to assume power is something
called the Night of the Long Knives,
okay? This is really important, because
the Nazi Party is a is an extreme
right-wing workers' party, right?
So, the army orders Hitler to kill all
their leaders.
And that's what And that's what
happened. This This is called the Night
of the Long Knives, of the Brownshirts.
The extreme right-wing was eliminated by
the army.
And the Nazi Party and now the army
Sorry. So, So, now the Nazi Party and
the army are now symbiotic, okay? They
rely on each other. From now on, the
Nazi Party will ensure total unity of
will at home through suppression of
people, okay? And the army will now go
march and conquer the world. Does that
make sense, guys? That's the plan.
All right.
So,
Adolf Hitler is the perfect man for the
job assigned him by the army, because he
is a fantastic speaker, okay? He's very
charismatic. Um we're going to listen to
his voice to So, you you can appreciate
how powerful his speech is his voice is.
What his speeches do
is he They create unity of will in
Germany, okay? Again, the goal is to
rejuvenate the nation
and re- reunite the German people,
right?
And so, the unity of will creates the
idea of synchronicity. Remember,
synchronicity is a secret to modern
warfare. Synchronicity means the the
organization and mobilization of your
people into one task. And this is
represented by the picture. If you can
get people to stand in line for a long
time,
you can fight a war, okay? And the
people and the nations that are really
strong at synchronicity, of course, are
Germany and Japan, right? Go to Germany,
go in the subway. Go to Japan, go in the
subway. No one is struggling against
each other, okay? No one's pushing.
Everyone Even though it's crowded,
people are standing exactly where they
should be standing, perfectly. That is
the idea of synchronicity. If you If
your people can do that, they can fight
a war and win the war, okay?
So,
this idea of unity of will, all right?
They can stand in line for a long, long
time, all right?
All right. So, we're going to look at
some speeches from Hitler from from
Hitler, okay? And we can see from his
his his speeches, he's trying to create
unity of will. He's trying to be the
Übermensch, the superman who will unite
his people like Napoleon and carry them
to victory through faith in in
themselves, okay? The unity of will.
If men wish to live, then they are
forced to kill others. The entire
struggle for survival is a conquest of
the means of existence, which in turn
results in elimination of others from
these same sources of sustenance. As
long as there are peoples on this earth,
there will be nations against nations,
and they will be forced to protect their
vital rights in the same way as the
individual is forced to protect his
rights. One is either the hammer or the
anvil. We confess that it is our purpose
to prepare the German people again for
the role of the hammer, okay?
So, he's saying we must unite as a
people. We must have unity of will if we
are if we are to triumph against our
enemies. All right.
Nothing is possible unless one will
command, a will which has to be obeyed
by others, beginning at the top and
ending only at the very bottom. This is
the expression of a authoritarian state,
not of a weak battling democracy, but of
a authoritarian state where everyone is
proud to obey because he knows I will
like like likewise be obeyed when I must
take command, all right?
Hitler is not being a dictator. He is
trying to create unity of will.
He is the leader. He's the Ubermensch.
But, that's only because God demanded
him to be so.
Okay? He will unite the
um German people into a hurricane, into
an ocean to crash itself upon the world.
In the course of my life, I have very
often been a prophet, and I have usually
been ridiculed for it. During the time
of my struggle for power, it was in the
first instance the Jewish race which
only received my prophecies with
laughter when I said that I would one
day take over the leadership of the
state, and with it that of the whole
nation, and that I would then, among
many other things, settle the Jewish
problem. Their laughter was uproarious,
but I think that for some time now they
have been laughing on the other side of
their face. Today, I will once more be a
prophet. The international Jewish
financiers in and outside Europe should
succeed in plunging the nations once
more into a world war, then the result
will not be the Bolshevization of the
earth and thus the victory of Jewry, but
the annihilation of the Jewish race in
Europe, okay?
So, we don't actually have any concrete
evidence
for the Holocaust, okay? So, one piece
of evidence for the Holocaust is this
speech by Hitler. But, I want I want to
explain what what he is saying here,
okay? What he's saying is, we, the
German nation, want to be left alone. We
want to be united. We want to be
unified.
But, the capitalists and the communists
all seek to undermine us. And who are
the communists? And who are the
capitalists? The Jews.
Okay?
It's the Jews who are a metaphor for an
a national elite group of individuals
who are conspiring to undermine the
vitality and the strength of the German
nation. All right, so that's what he's
saying here. All right.
Um 1939, September 1st is the
beginning of World War II, okay?
And so, he's going to explain why this
is happening. As a National Socialist
and as a German soldier, I enter upon
the struggle with stout heart. My whole
life has been nothing but one struggle
for my people, for its restoration, and
for Germany. There is only one watchword
for that struggle favoring this people,
one word I have never learned, that is
surrender, okay? So, he's telling the
people, we're going to fight this war
again. Why did we lose World War I?
Because we didn't have faith. We
surrendered.
If we all came together and we fought to
the very battle end, we would we would
have prevailed against our enemies,
okay?
It is quite unimportant whether we
ourselves live, but it is essential that
our people shall live, that Germany
shall live. The sacrifice that is
demanded of us is not greater than the
sacrifice that many generations have
made. If we form a community closely
bound together by vows, ready for
anything, resolved never to surrender,
then our will will master every hardship
and difficulty, okay? It is the unity of
will that matters.
All right. 1942, November 8th,
it's basically
um at a time in history when the Germans
understand they've lost the war. The
Americans are now in are now in the war.
The Americans are getting ready to
invade Europe.
The German invasion of the Soviet Union
has failed, okay? They're bogged down in
the Soviet Union.
Germany is
uh overstretched.
It The entire world has allied itself
itself against Germany, okay? So, the
war is about to be lost. But, but let's
let's look at what Hitler has to say.
It is with the same conviction that I
now stand before you and has never left
me either since the day on which, as an
unknown man in the city, I began to
struggle first for the soul of the
German people and then on beyond the
city for more and more followers. In the
beginning, I did not have much more to
give than faith, the faith that if
anyone pursues a just aim, I will
unchanging and another strict loyalty
and never lets himself be diverted from
it, but puts everything into it, then
others will be found who are determined
to be his followers, and that from this
whole and ever stronger faith must
gradually radiate to the whole people.
Okay? So, this is unity of will.
We reject reality. Reality does not
matter because we impose our will on
reality. As long as we have faith, as
long as as long as we have unity of
will, we will triumph, okay?
All right.
So, let's go back to the beginning. We
were talking about Kaliningrad, right?
Um
it is one of the greatest injustices
in human history that Königsberg, which
was
for the longest time
uh the cradle of human civilization, the
epicenter of the Enlightenment,
it is now completely destroyed,
okay?
Um but,
um and this is
a really
This is an idea from Wagner, okay?
Um by destroying this,
the world has cursed itself, okay? Let
me Let me explain why.
First of all,
the German question now is more relevant
than ever before. You've destroyed
Königsberg, but you have not destroyed
the desire for unity among the German
people,
okay? So, this is the
um memory that will not fade.
All right. So, will the Germans seek
vengeance? Will another Hitler arise to
unite the German people?
Now, what you guys don't know is that
the Prussians were one of the main
forces opposing Hitler as well as
inhibiting Hitler, okay? Because Prussia
had a very proud culture and it was the
strongest
part of uh Germany. But, now that they
destroyed Prussia, if if another Hitler
arises, there's really nothing to stop
him, okay? That's the first problem.
Second question is,
um okay, let's go back to this map.
Europe and Russia are about to go to war
with each other, right?
Okay. Well, if you are Europe and you go
into Ukraine, you're going to be
slaughtered, okay? But,
this is Kaliningrad, Russian territory,
500,000 Russians, right? You can
blockade Kaliningrad.
You understand?
So, this could be the start of World War
III right here.
Does that make sense to you guys?
If the Europeans blockade Kaliningrad
and they start to try to starve the
people, Putin would have no choice but
to intervene.
Okay?
But, the main problem is this.
Königsberg was one of the main
intellectual, scientific, and cultural
centers of Europe. That its loss reduced
the innovative potential of humanity.
All right. So, what I will show you next
class when we discuss Kant is
science comes from philosophy,
okay? Culture leads to philosophy, which
leads to science, which leads to
technology.
You cannot have science independent of
philosophy. When you destroy a center of
philosophical philosophical innovation,
you destroy a center for scientific
progress,
okay? So, that This is something that we
will discuss in depth next class
as well.
Um so, when we look at Kant.
So, that is
uh Germany.
Okay, any questions
about what we've learned so far? Was Was
this clear to you guys?
Okay?
Any Any questions?
How can Hitler be grown
To me? How can Hitler be grown like
that? Like
personal charisma or something.
Yeah, okay. So, um where did Hitler come
from, right? How did Hitler become so
charismatic? Okay.
Um so,
there's a lot of randomness to life,
okay?
There's There's There's a lot of like
randomness going on in life.
So, uh the army wanted to inhibit the
growth of the socialist left-wing
movement, and it did so by financing
these right-wing parties. The Nazi Party
was just one of many parties that the
army financed and supported, okay?
Um Hitler
became a spy, and he became part of this
movement, and as such, he became um he
he became uh exposed to a lot of the
ideas of the Nazi Party. The Nazi Party,
a lot of the ideas come from Nietzsche
and Wagner and and others uh as well,
okay?
Um
and over time,
Hitler came to believe that he was the
Messiah.
Okay, he was the Messiah dedicated to
restoring German
unity.
Okay? And um
I mean, like this is hard to understand,
but
um human population is very diverse, so
you always have a subset of people
who have these
uh delusion of grandeur.
And if in a certain circumstances,
they will be proven right,
okay? That doesn't make sense, okay? So,
another way of saying this is, the army
needed someone to play the part of the
Ubermensch, the superman who could unite
the German German people and create
national unity so the army could seek
its vengeance against
uh the rest of Europe and unite the
German people. Okay? So, they're looking
for this role
um, and then Hitler auditioned for this
role, and he got the role. Okay? Does
that make sense?
Um, and this is important because
um,
towards the end of the class, we'll
discuss Donald Trump.
And what I what I will show you is
um,
this is exactly what what happened with
Donald Trump.
Okay? So, the German mili- Sorry, so the
American military needs an Ubermensch to
lead America to war against Putin.
And there were and there were different
people who auditioned, Biden auditioned,
he was terrible, Harris auditioned, he
was terrible, and they picked Donald
Trump. Okay? So, it's a very similar
pattern. It's a very familiar pattern in
human history. You can also argue that
Napoleon was the same way.
Okay? And what makes
these people um,
these people different from us,
Napoleon, Hitler,
uh, Julius Caesar, Trump, is they are
the total expression of the desire and
will. You understand? They have no no
compassion, no sympathy for anyone.
They believe they are here on a divine
mission. They are complete They are the
will itself, and they are and they must
impose their will on others to save the
world. Does that make sense?
So, you look at Donald Trump, okay? If
you want to understand Hitler, look at
Donald Trump. The guy is like almost 80.
He doesn't sleep.
Okay? He's off traveling around the
world all the time. The guy The guy in
his um,
when he was campaigning, he was giving
like three speeches a day, right? He
would get up in the morning at 4:00, fly
somewhere, give his two-hour speech.
People loved him, then he would get on
get on a plane, fly somewhere else. And
he would He could not stop talking to
reporters, okay? He has too much energy
that comes from the perfect expression
of the will. You understand? Donald
Trump is all will, all desire, all ego,
and no sympathy, no empathy, no
compassion. That's Hitler and Napoleon.
But, when they want their citizen or
their people to think they're like too
reckless
reckless or violent?
Yeah, that that that's a great question.
So, won't people rebel against us? Won't
people
think this is reckless? And so, what
Schopenhauer
and Nietzsche and others will say is
what we what we want first and foremost
is a return to unity of will, right? In
the very beginning, the will was God.
That's the Big Bang.
And then the the will expanded itself,
right? And so, we find ourselves alone
in an ocean of alienation.
And what our hearts really
aspire to is return to a unity of will.
And so, when someone says, "You can be
part of a movement to transform the
world." That's much more appealing to us
psychologically than to say, "Oh, you
know what?
Um, come to school, do your homework,
get good grades, do the SAT, get into a
top 50 American school, become an
accountant, and for 50 years do
something meaningless,
uh, but make a lot of money, and then
you you will die a happy person."
Like like seriously, what what like like
there's there's there's no competition,
right? There's no competition.
Donald Trump is saying to Americans, "We
will make America great again. We will
be a civilization a great civilization
again."
It will require sacrifice. It will
require my sacrifice,
but it will be worth it because
we will make the world
whole again.
All right?
Okay? So, again, when you listen to the
Hitler speeches,
from our perspective, it's not that
persuasive, okay? But, when you're in a
crowd of people, and this man is
speaking to you with his voice, it's
like Wagner, okay? It's like going to a
concert. The music fills you, and it and
it inspires your heart. Okay? It makes
you want to be the Ubermensch.
Okay? Hitler is just the example, but
he's saying you can you can you can also
aspire to be the Ubermensch if you are
willing to sacrifice your life
for the unity of will.
Okay?
So, this is really important. This is
far more appealing to people than
the idea of materialism.
All right? This is religion, right?
Hitler's creating a new religion.
And it's intoxicating.
Right? I mean like World War II, I mean
I mean, the fact that German the Germans
were able to fight for so long against
the entire world.
I mean, it's incredible. I mean like it
was America, Britain, France, Soviet
Union against
the Germans. And it's the fact that the
Germans fought so bravely
and fought to the very bitter end. I
mean, it just shows you the power of
unity of will.
Okay?
And what this also tells us is
these things don't die, okay? You can
kill a civilization, you can destroy a
city, you can massacre a people, but you
cannot destroy the desire for unity of
will, because that's what fundamentally
makes us human.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay, great.
Any more questions, guys? But but but
that's a great question. Thank you.
Does this Does it Does that make make
sense to you? Yeah. Okay. Okay, great.
Okay.
Any more questions, guys?
Okay. So, um,
next week we will do Kant, okay? And
Kant will lead us to Marx and Freud and
um, modernity.
Okay?
Okay.